why are you just standing there in
gawking you kajita our objective is
taking back east to me and the others
yet you're stumbling here of all places
what's more whether it's a red and white
battle for training purposes or if we
are only sous chefs it matters not this
is a Kachina the place where you and I
do battle hello and welcome to shokugeki
101 the series that breaks down everyone
in everything in the world of shokugeki
no souma today we are going to examine
aldini talk to me one of sohma's
hot-blooded rivals and close friends
Takumi aldini is a blond blue-eyed
student from toad suki Academy the young
Italian hates losing and is easily
flustered when caught making a mistake
he takes great pride in his family's
restaurant trattoria aldini and holds
intense grudges against anyone who
speaks poorly against his heritage
family or friends Takumi first appeared
during the orientation ceremony but
didn't join the main cast until the
first day of the toad tsuki friendship
and rapport training camp the twin
eldini brothers talked me and ISA me
grew up in a Japanese Italian household
and learned to cook in their uncle's who
stood on day taka me exhibited prodigy
like cooking skills at the tender age of
five and his exquisite mastery of the
Italian cuisine drew in many customers
although talking Meowth shined his
brother east of me in terms of raw
talent from a young age the brothers
vowed to combine their strengths and
make territorial Dini the best
restaurant in Italy when the boys
reached middle school age their uncle
advised them to attend Tatsuki Academy
they easily progressed through the
middle school sector honing their skills
as both individual chefs as well as an
amazing team and although talk to me as
the eldest of the brothers aldini ISA me
is the mature one of the two and often
calls his brothers fiery temper even so
talk to me is very protective of his
younger brother and cannot forgive those
who insult him and while he Samia is
talking his greatest support and best
friend he's also talking his greatest
rival however Yuki you know sama stands
as a close second pushing talk to me to
the very limits of his own Italian
cooking style the heart of which is his
unique cooking tool the Mezzaluna the
Mezzaluna is a crescent-shaped knife
with double handles a tool which
requires an extreme amount of skill
precision and control operate Takumi is
able to use this knife with incredible
fan
speed and he even invented a special
move called la danza de la spada
that only he can perform using the knife
he starts spinning the Mezzaluna like a
baton speeding it up to an incredibly
high speed with each flick of his
fingers he then uses the Mezzaluna to
chop his ingredients precisely in almost
instantaneously la danza de la spada is
described as a sword danced alchemy
performs before the cutting board the
Mezzaluna however is not just a simple
tool it represents the connection
between him and his brother Issa me the
twin brothers are the strongest tag-team
at kutsuki Academy and became known as
totes keys unbeatable twins they
understand each other's strengths and
weaknesses well enough to bring out the
best in each other's cooking as the best
italian chef in his year currently
enrolled in Totsuka academy many of
talking these dishes stem from italian
cuisine but he often adds a twist
showing that he is not only a master in
one form of cuisine but is also
incredibly skilled in mixing different
cooking styles the dish talk to me is
most remembered for is a classic Italian
insalata frittata which he made during
the breakfast buffet challenge during
the totes key friendship and rapport
training camp the frittata he made with
eggs and cheese is meant to be broken
into little pieces and eaten with a
solid combining the rough chunks of
frittata with vegetables like tomatoes
cucumbers and lettuce all of this is
finished off with Parmesan cheese and a
drizzle of balsamic vinegar the
different textures and fluffiness from
the frittata and the crispness of the
vegetables create the distinct flavour
of the dish another dish that shows his
mastery not only of the Italian cuisine
but also spices was his Napolitan curry
fettuccine that he created during the
43rd annual toasty autumn election
preliminary round although it seemed at
first like a classic Napolitan dish
rather than slathering the fettuccine
pasta in a traditional sauce
he actually topped the pasta noodles
with curry the curry itself was made out
of beef shin chicken bone stock fennel
and green cardamon topped off with
pepper bacon and mushrooms taking his
cooking to a further level Takumi added
a twist to the pasta noodles themselves
creating fettuccine noodles with three
layers the outer layer consisted of
classic dough kneaded with tumeric and
the
innermost layer was made of thin
Parmesan cheese a secret layer between
the outer and inner layers was formed
from tamari soy sauce melting the cheese
and the dough perfectly however tok amis
confidence in his own cooking wavered
after he was crushed in the autumn
election quarterfinals mimasaka Subaru
used his superhuman tres abilities to
not only copy Takumi's exact cooking
methods and way of thinking but also to
plan a step ahead and beat talk--i me
with an improved version of the same
dish as a result Subaru took Takumi's
Mezzaluna as their match doubled as a
shokugeki furthermore it was actually
soma who won back the Mezzaluna this in
itself put a great dent in Takumi's ego
in confidence as a chef all right I'd
like to put up a bit of a warning for
those of you who are anime only Watchers
as will now be heading into heavy
spoiler territory I would be sorely
remiss to talk about all this Italian
cooking without bringing up Takumi's
pizza if you are a manga reader you'll
recall one particularly special dish
that talked to me made when he was going
up against at SIA eizan during the
rebels vs. central Raj Monte cuisine the
doppio Mezzaluna Pizza combines Italian
and Japanese cuisine into two halves
resembling a half moon the side that is
meant to be in first is topped with rich
she-goat any beef and needle thin cut
ginger the other side is a magical
Quattro formaggio using mozzarella
parmigiano-reggiano gorgonzola and
ricotta which is seasoned with black
pepper and although this dish would have
been great on its own Takumi actually
shows great observation skills
predicting exactly what a zijn would do
and using eizan's dish as an appetizer
to strengthen the flavors of his pizza
after the regimen de cuisine Takumi
actually became a member of the new
elite 10 council taking the seventh seat
for himself and even being acknowledged
by the world gourmet organization with
an invitation to enter blue a world
youth cooking championship where young
chefs from all over the world gather and
compete against each other it's during
the blue arc that we learned that
how can we actually engaged with
yukihira soma in nearly daily shokugeki
over his Mezzaluna through their
constant duels they actually became an
excellent tag team in the kitchen skills
which shone brightly during their duel
against the noir chef Don comma together
soma and Takumi were able to create a
yin yang terrine mixing cheese and
turtle two very different ingredients
that like soma and talk to me harmonize
perfectly in the dish unfortunately for
talking me advancing in the blue
tournament pitted him against knockety
arena he was so thoroughly defeated by
the possessor of the god tongue that he
even acknowledged her as seat zero of
the Elite ten one step beyond yukihira
soma
however lde certainly takes defeat with
grace and like soma has learned to use
failure as a stepping stone for reaching
new heights and now for some fun facts
about aldini talk to me both parts of
the name Takumi and eldini are very
common names in the tuscany region of
Florence in Italy aldini means wise and
experience quite fitting for him after
everything he's learned through his
education at Totsuka speaking of which
Takamine actually has a fan club at the
academy which was formed only one month
after he entered the middle school
section Takumi and ISA me each carry a
bottle of aldini olive oil at all times
and thanks to mimasaka Subarus very
thorough investigations we actually have
a lot of truly useless facts about
Takumi aldini Takumi is said to be
afraid of heights to call his home twice
a month set two alarms before going to
sleep and to prefer showers to baths he
also wears checkered pattern underwear
thanks Subaru for all of this truly
useless insight about talk to me but
that pretty much does it for all Dini
talk to me if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produces in
general then please do consider donating
to the new world revue patreon as the
support of all you amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style and please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe as it also helps
to support us in
and if you'd like to join in on the fun
at any time then please do head over to
our discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment on
who what or where you'd like to see
featured on the next show kageki 101
[Music]